80 are gone from the daily correct yes
so how do you run the company with only
20 of the staff
uh it turns out uh you don't need uh
well that many people to run Twitter but
80 that's a lot
um yes uh
of it I mean if you're not trying to run
some sort of uh
glorified activist organization uh with
it and you're not care that much about
censorship then you can really let go of
a lot of people turns out
Tucker laughs and Elon is grinning they
say yeah we we fired or allowed to quit
and retire
80 of the company it's just a feed it's
basically like a group text and Twitter
is not that complicated Elon Musk is a
guy who builds Rockets who builds very
Advanced and expensive cars Twitter
doesn't need that kind of Manpower
unless
you're building an activist organization